I just
got the new Model 3 Highland two days ago
and one of the disadvantages of Tesla was
they had the best battery and so
on, the best technology, software and so
on but things
still rattled a bit, you just have to
say  Still, I think it was
the best car and I enjoyed driving it for a long time,
but when you
slammed the door there were certain things
that just weren't processed on top notch.
Now the Model 3 Highland
has arrived, it's so perfectly
processed and it even rattles  nothing
more, which makes me so happy because he has
now made it in production
and he is also building profitably, which
when you see how much Ford and others
lose per car, that means he has
really achieved something again that
was enormous, not only that  the best eV
but now also an outstanding
car with gaps and so on to
build profitably deep deep
respect as an
entrepreneur